this is just the best I think you're
gonna like this you know how it's
usually the left that says socializing
healthcare would save money it would
work well it's a good idea it's fiscally
conservative and the right insists that
it's too expensive we can't afford it it
would run up the debt to socialized
healthcare we've had economists on the
show who explained the math to us
for example UMass economist Gerald
Friedman but the right ignores people
like Gerry because they say that's a
left-wing Bernie supporter he can't be
trusted
there is now a Koch brother backed study
which found that the government cost for
Medicare for all would be lower than if
we stuck with exactly what we are doing
right now the entire cost of Medicare
for all for 10 years would be thirty two
point six trillion dollars that's less
than the current system which will cost
the government a little over 33 trillion
dollars for a decade the study is from
the Mercatus or Mercatus Center it's
called the costs of a national
single-payer health care system this is
a libertarian think-tank the Koch
brothers give them money and I want to
make sure I'm presenting this clearly
because there's been so much
misinformation about this in media in
right-wing media and in corporate media
as well the study says the cost to the
government would go down right the
government would save about 850 billion
on prescription costs about 1.6 trillion
on administrative costs this doesn't
include the bulk of the program's costs
which would be paid for through income
taxes by businesses and individuals okay
I'm not trying to hide that what I'm
talking about is that the cost to the
government would go down slightly if we
were to go to Medicare for all of course
it costs money to do this but the cost
to the government would go down then it
becomes would you rather pay more in
taxes as an individual or a business but
not pay for health insurance for
yourself or for your employees and the
study is actually probably wrong in its
assessment that Medicare would cost a
ton more in taxes than what people
already pay for health insurance
the big deception when people report
about this reports say we would have to
put two three four five six seven eight
percent tax on income in order to pay
for this thing right but how much would
be saved by not paying health insurance
premiums and co-payments and deductibles
right away the right will say it'll cost
fifty trillion for this thing it in
taxes but it might save sixty trillion
in health insurance payments right and
that's what you really have to have to
account for there's some very simple
math here that we can think about if you
make $50,000 a year
Bernie's plan said you need a 2.2
percent tax on salary call it three
percent if you make fifty thousand a
year a three percent tax is a hundred
and twenty five bucks a month if you're
currently single you probably already
pay more than 125 a month towards your
health insurance if you have a family
you pay way more than a hundred and
twenty five bucks a month in health
insurance consider the numbers from the
corporate perspective if you are a
company and you're big enough to offer
health insurance if you have to pay
seven percent payroll tax for employee
health insurance that would be thirty
five hundred bucks for the year per
employee or two ninety one per month you
probably are already paying that or more
for your employees already the
difference being that the employees will
be more likely to go and get seen when
they're not feeling well because they
don't have a copay or a coinsurance or
whatever don't be tricked into thinking
that the Mac math is really complex
everybody would pay more in taxes for
Medicare for all but then health
insurance premiums co-pays coinsurance
deductibles and prescription cost go
away and every serious analysis has
pointed out that it would be a net
savings and now even the coke funded
think tank the Mercatus Center says the
cost of the government would also go
down do you think Pat that media is
deliberately misreporting the results of
this study or do you think they just
don't understand it because it is sort
of complex they well it costs thirty two
trillion
compared to 33 trillion that that's
actually a decrease it depends on what
kind of media you're talking about
okay I'm not surprised that Fox News
isn't running a headline here that says
study shows that actually Medicare or
bra would save money in the long term
we're not gonna see that from them right
UC 32.3 built a trillion dollars in
costs that's a big price tag we can't
afford that yeah I think you're probably
right I think depending on which media
outlet you're talking about some are
deliberately off obfuscating some are
just very confused by this but this is
actually proof from the right that this
would be better in terms of government
spending it's the fiscally conservative
thing to do and we have numerous studies
from all across the political spectrum
which point out that the cost of the
additional income tax to fund this
program would more than likely be
smaller than what people currently pay
for health insurance at this point if
you're not convinced it has to be
because you're not willing to see it and
you're committed to not understanding it
discuss this with us on our subreddit as
many of you already are david pakman.com
slash re d di t quick break next i will
debate socialism versus social democracy
with Peter coffin today's program is
made possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman this is something I really
believe in better help gives you access
to fully licensed and experienced
psychologists and therapists through
your phone or computer I have been
talking for years about the problem
around people not seeking help because
of the stigma around mental health
services because of the cost of mental
health services and all you have to do
with better help is go to better help
calm slash Pakman answer some basic
questions you'll be matched with a
therapist that will be right for you you
can change therapists if you don't think
that it's a good fit it's less expensive
than seeing someone in person you will
still get the professional help and it
is unlimited you can talk to a therapist
every day from home or wherever you are
go to better help calm slash Pakman it
is so easy to sign up and get started
we've put a link in the description
if you're watching on YouTube better
help calm /pa que ma n if you've been
wanting to talk to somebody but for
whatever reason haven't please go to
better help calm /pa que ma n